alright guys so The Avengers trailer the
official trailer was just released I
just watched it and I received many
messages from you guys Chris please tell
me what you thought of it please as soon
as you see it please tell me so I'm
going to in the end it would be every
man for himself
I literally have nothing but good things
to say about this I I was actually
incredibly blown away by that trailer
because I when you when you think of a
movie and you see production photos
somehow I think it's easy to like get an
idea in your head of what you think it's
going to be and then when you actually
see a trailer that's why when people ask
me if I'm looking forward to a movie I
always say let me see the trailer first
there's never like when the dark night
teaser is released it was just it was
just the bat symbol with dialogue when
they released the official trailer with
the Joker everyone was like dude I'm on
board
hold my word I'm on board and that's
kind of what it is right now with this
trailer it was an idea to bring together
a group of remarkable people
so when we needed them they could fight
the battles but we never could
I saw the teaser trailer which is really
just like you know the word Avengers
with some audio I saw the thing after
Captain America which was really cool
but now this I am on board this looks so
stylish Lee directed by Joss Whedon
which i think is so cool that he's able
to get something big like this finally
when he's done so many like fanboy
things or just so you know like a set
group of people appreciated his work now
we have a thing where a whole bunch of
people are gonna be able to see it and
he's just I bet you this is like his
ultimate dream is directing this movie
gentlemen what are you prepared and to
do no offense but I don't play well with
others
big man soon armor take that away where
are you genius billionaire playboy
philanthropist all the characters looked
intact all the characters that we've
already seen especially Robert Downey
jr. he was I mean you can just tell he
is Iron Man in that trailer and he is
just loving it this looks so great I
mean I'm really really him factually
impressed about this and I'm geeking out
about it right now because I love it
everyone looks great Hawkeye Scarlett
Johansson everyone Nick Fury is looking
awesome Captain America Thor is even a
part where it looks like Thor and
Captain America fight a brief little
moment work where Thor brings up his
hammer towards Captain America I was
like mm interesting there's something
that I know that people are wondering
and people want to see us and well they
want to know what we think of the Hulk
and a lot of people are wondering about
that they haven't shown you really
anything and Mark Ruffalo's characters
really been kept in the you know really
under wraps you do get a little peek at
something in the trailer I'll just say
that awesome I'm a pleased nerd right
now I'm very happy
but we can't protect the Earth
you can damage circle of engine
so yeah The Avengers trailer awesome
fantastic really looking forward to it
it just looks so good
it really does okay I got nothing bad to
say about it I'm very pleased with what
I saw dr. Pinner your work on paralleled
and I'm a huge fan of the way you lose
control and turn into an enormous green
rage monster Thanks
I'm gonna provide the link I can
actually do that it's official it's not
some dumb leaked thing I can actually
say here look down there is the official
link so check it out and tell me what
you thought and I'm about to head off to
a screening of the thing I'll be back
later today with a review for that